this is Jocko podcast number 378 with
Echo Charles and me Jocko willink good
evening Echo good evening
I was in his control as soon as we stood
close to each other I had no time to
even hold or grapple him
I was taken into the ground and I got
choked at first it was difficult to
breathe I felt it working enough so I
was wondering if I should tap as I
promised Carlos
well this is what I've never told
anybody before it seems I went
unconscious while I was thinking about
what to do to give up or not
if chimura had continued to choke me I
would have died for sure
but since I didn't give up Kimura let go
of the choke and went into the next
technique being released from the choke
and the pain from the next technique
revived me and I continued to fight
Kimura went to his grave without ever
knowing the fact that I was finished if
possible
I wish I could have talked about the
fight with him and let him know about it
Kimura was strong strong and a gentleman
he spoke in my ear in Japanese good good
while catching me with an arm lock I
don't understand Japanese at all but
Strangely I was encouraged by his voice
it gave me power
I was anxious about it so I asked him
later he said I was admiring your heart
same to him
I think I got the authentic samurai
Spirit from him
I might have been Japanese in my
previous life
and that right there is a little quote
from the great Elio Gracie founder of
Gracie Jiu Jitsu
which
in my opinion what do they say in my
humble opinion sure in my humble opinion
kinda makes him the founder of modern
martial arts agree disagree moderate yep
at least you have to that's
consideration uh
what do they say when they say in the
conversation right yeah in the
conversation for CH for the founding of
modern mixed martial arts Elio Gracie
has to be in the conversation 100
percent
and it's a quote from an interview that
is quoted in a book and the book is
called Kimura
the triumphs and tragedy of Japan's
greatest and most controversial Judo
champion this book was originally given
to me recently by my friend and training
partner Miha you know me huh of course
you know me you trained with me yes sir
sometimes yeah time to time you arrive
at the training
Zone yeah it goes down for sure uh so
Miha we went on a little trip lately he
he gave me this book to check out and I
thought
let's check it out and Miha he's you
know obviously he's a Jitsu black belt
he's also a judo black belt
but he thought I would like the book so
read the book and this is a book
obviously about Kimura this is a
there's a submission hold also called
Kimura
it's one of my favorites I understand
it's named the the submission hold has
other names people called other things
but by now pretty much everyone calls it
a Kimura and is named after him that's
the move that he put on Elio Gracie and
we'll get into that Elio Gracie
match that they had you know Elio Gracie
was a lot smaller and they had a good
scrap but he eventually had the towel
thrown in so he didn't get his arm
removed from his body by Kimura but
interesting life
incredible fighter and I just wanted to
uh jump into this book
you got any background on camera over
there
um just the same as as you just that
right there yeah he was uh he was
already a super well-known guy in the
martial arts world back in those days oh
yeah
but yeah he was one of the he's kind of
the main catalyst for Elio Gracie from
what I understand from what like yeah
and going and you said you actually
meant you said um the one of the main
what do you say found Elio Gracie being
the founder of modern martial arts mixed
martial arts I think so yeah although
they were doing Valley tutu and stuff in
in other ways or whatever but yeah how
it kind of came to America and now what
it is right now MMA I would say like if
it wasn't if it wasn't for
if it wasn't for Elio Gracie Gracie Jiu
Jitsu correct you wouldn't quite have
what we have no and the evolution of
martial arts
in the last I mean we could say in the
last six months but did you take the
last 10 years it's crazy but since 1993
since that first UFC the evolution has
been incredible the entire world of
martial arts has changed I mean it used
to be a totally different thing oh yeah
in 1979 yeah what martial arts were was
a totally different thing than what it
is now yeah the main one so back in So
Gracie Jiu Jitsu technically on record
was found in 1925. maada came over and
taught the Gracie family
what he called Jiu Jitsu which was very
close to Judo yes so yeah and then you
see and so he became sort of this Source
because it kind of changed it the source
and then the main vein was actually
horian Gracie who he was the oldest son
where he brought it to American was okay
we need to like show everybody so he's
the one who made the first UFC put hoist
in there and but they were all training
they're all doing it but it wasn't
revealed to the world because of not or
it was later because of media you'll see
this big spectacle or whatever and then
slowly it slowly started to spread
through that main vein and then in 2005
when Ultimate Fighter came out that was
when media really took it
turning into a little reality show
because that's when reality shows
started getting their legs you know yeah
so boom they mix that up boom from there
was just this massive massive explosion
but it's crazy to think about like these
guys back in the day they knew something
that people just didn't know they knew
something that people did not know and
nowadays look you get into a street
fight there's a chance people know what
the guard is they might know how to slap
a guillotine on they might know you know
what the mount is like they're gonna
know this stuff yeah
and if you go into any
Jiu Jitsu school like they're gonna know
a lot of it yeah
man back in the day like when I when I
got when I trained Jiu-Jitsu for the
first time with Master Chief Steve
Bailey there was no comprehension of
what was happening there was no
comprehension at all this did not this
was not a thing at all there was no
there was not even like a thought of
what was happening it wasn't like the
the idea that someone would take your
arm and put it in a position where you
would have to say uncle yeah it didn't
make sense it wasn't a thing yeah
especially if the guy wasn't bigger than
you so it went from not being a thing at
all to being the thing yeah think about
that transition so these guys
and Judo you know we we've done some
podcasts on Judo we've done some
podcasts on Kano to talk about where
that developed from but Judo very
powerful very powerful martial art
and and it is
you know the roots of Jiu Jitsu see it's
interesting because Judo is rooted in
Jiu Jitsu but modern Jiu Jitsu is rooted
in Judo again back at it
so anyways this guy one of the greatest
judokas ever we're gonna roll into it
we're gonna look at his book here and
here we go
was born
on the southern island of Kyushu and I
apologize for the Japanese speakers out
there I don't speak Japanese at all and
I mangle all words so born September
19th September 10th 1917 little is known
about his family background although the
family was said to be poor according to
one biography of chimera at the age of
around 10.
he began to help his father collect
River gravel and stones to sell they had
to dig the gravel from the river bottom
and deliver it to a nearby truck on
Sundays and holidays when kimira was out
of school he would work from 4 a.m to 6
p.m hauling gravel
and experience later credited with
helping him build a strong body you got
to have a little bit of Mythology going
on here when you picture this 10 year
old kid hauling gravel out of the river
Cold River got having to go out I mean
well how deep is he going to get it is
it knee-deep or is he having to get a
little breath hold activity going on and
he's doing that from 4 AM to 6 p.m
that's what's happening
uh
his uncle also encouraged the youngster
to drink carp's blood which is said to
be good for the heart so there you go
he's just ripping the heads off of fish
and drinking their blood while carrying
rocks out of the river for 14 hours a
day
you know like you're gonna be ready for
some Jiu Jitsu or some judo competitions
Japanese children were generally
protected and not disciplined until they
were about five at that age they began
to face strict discipline especially
from their fathers this often LED young
boys to act out with with a rebellious
streak and based on his later actions
Kimura almost certainly developed into a
mischievous child when he entered school
at the age of about six by the time he
was around nine or ten Kimura was
relatively large for his age and appears
to have become something of a ringleader
among the Mischief Makers in the school
during his fourth grade year isn't it
crazy I mean we're talking about a guy's
fourth grade year we got some Deets bro
some details on this guy the students
were mustered to engage in oh soji a
thorough Mass cleaning of the school
with his teacher Mr tagawa absent Kimura
snuck away dashing to a nearby snack
shop and gobbling down five or six man
two or steamed stuffed buns returning to
his class he saw several students moving
Mr tagawa's desk he ran toward the desk
and jumped onto it causing the desk to
noisily collapse
Chimera jumped up and down with Joy
screaming Bonsai bonsai
and then he this there's quotes in here
and I looked for this book that he has
an autobiography out there somewhere or
it's taken from interviews I couldn't
find either one of them Miha looked for
him as well I couldn't find it he says
this this is now Kimura talking suddenly
someone grabbed me firmly in the rear
lapel and pulled me backward when I
turned my head I found Mr tagawa who I
thought was absent glaring at me with a
very scary look he yelled idiot face and
slapped me in the face he then threw me
to the floor he pulled me up slapped me
and threw me to the floor again after
this I was scolded in the teacher's room
and stood in the corridor
after this incident I decided to get
even with Mr tagawa
I thought about how to get revenge on
him for about a week and investigated
his background
I then found out that he was a first Don
in Judo I thought is Judo such a
formidable art then I would be able to
throw him if I became a second Don soon
after this I entered into the Shotokan
Dojo nearby by elementary school so he's
got a little bit of a streak right
imagine being 10 years old or whatever
he is fourth grade what are you in for
yeah fourth grade you're 10 years old so
he's 10 years old this teacher he's
actually being a jackass and the teacher
slaps him around a little bit and he
starts plotting Revenge researches it
does background checks figure out what's
this new deal where his weaknesses finds
out he's only a first Dawn in Judo once
I become a second Dawn I'll be able to
take him
all right it goes on to say Mr tagawa's
corporal punishment and humiliation of
the young Kimura was exactly what he
needed he began to practice Judo and
after only about a year he entered his
first competition which they call Shiite
I think
a match with the Nakayama Dojo which was
located about three miles away he faced
a much bigger eighth grader Chimera
attempted a body drop throw and a major
outer reaping throw to no effect then
attacked with the major inner reaping
throw but his opponent reversed the
technique on him and pinned him to the
ground with the top four corners hold
for the win
Kimura continued to practice hard driven
on by the memory of his defeat in eighth
grade he entered
a prefectural Sumo tournament and placed
second he narrowly missed the first
place when he threw his opponent by a
sotogari but the referee declared that
his foot had been out of bounds this
success and probably a growing
reputation in Judo circles raised
kimira's visibility a recruiter for
chinsei junior high school visited his
home and invited Kimura
to attend the school and play either for
the Sumo or Judo team in 1932 chimura
entered chinsei and became a fantastic
of a training Fanatic in addition to
practicing at school he trained at the
kawakita dojo three times a week
at the butokudin and the Imperial fifth
High School altogether he REM he later
remembered he practiced Judo five hours
a day and did 300 push-ups daily
so we're getting into it that
that idea of when people get introduced
into being dominated physically
dominated
can have
I guess it can have a bunch of outcomes
but the outcomes that we remember or it
either makes you say whatever this is
I'm going to learn it so that I can
never make sure this never happens to me
or you can say whatever this is I hate
it and I'm gonna avoid it at all costs
so this never happens to me and I'm sure
there's some gray area but
especially I think
10 years ago what people didn't really
understand what was happening they
didn't understand that it was a
technique yeah
and if they figured out that it was a
technique they say cool I'm going to
learn these techniques if they didn't
understand it was a technique they just
ran away from it
sorcery who's the first person that put
you to tap uh
probably my friend Jeremy Jeremy's
Ruskin oh yeah but keep in mind this is
uh you know back so 1993 UFC one
into this is 94 ish when you we bought
the videotapes the grace with the Gracie
in action no no they weren't greasy in
action they were the the instructions
yeah the VHS one do you remember Gracie
in action yes I do yeah I still visit
those very often because those are those
they've kind of
look they age well because you still get
to see it but
that's when you get to see what I was
talking about earlier just zero
knowledge like people that literally had
no idea that the concept of a fight was
to get the position and get someone to
think about that that's a totally
different concept yes that's a totally
different concept it's it's like a
foreign concept that you could that you
might not understand at all yeah and and
to prove that's actually probably more
true than that even sounds as far as you
saying it so and this is why I know this
so the reason that I watch them a lot
now is because I watch them with my son
because he don't know that you know his
idea of like oh let's play fight right
and he always wants to play fight so
what is it he's kicking me he's punching
me and stuff like that and he's like
let's not so I'll like grab him and
block his bunches whatever and I'll put
him in like a choke or whatever or put
him in Mountain be like can't fight from
here can you he's like no no we're not
doing Jiu Jitsu we're fighting that's
what he's he'd say he thinks Jujitsu is
just fun like a game and then he'll
think the real fighting is just a
punching and kicking part so I was like
hey you what you don't understand is
jujitsu is both the punching kicking and
the Jujitsu and I'm saying the Jujitsu
when faced with just the punching and
kicking if you don't put them together
like you'll lose to the Jiu Jitsu he's
like what are you talking you know so I
show him the Gracie in action when I was
like look this is all fight watch this
guy he doesn't Punch or kick or nothing
thing he just used Jiu Jitsu and these
guys are really fighting look they're
really really fighting and he'd watch
them and watch them and watch him and
then now he slowly understands oh and he
sees any understands now but it's true
because yeah when you see oh yeah two
people got in a fight oh it's always who
knocked this guy out or kicked this
guy's head or even when we watch on the
movies when they get in a fight oh
that's all punching and kicking you know
so like our idea is a little bit skewed
in that way or it was anyway you
remember we talked on a couple podcasts
ago about the thought I think it's the
fosberry Flop the guy that jumped over
the uh
was the high jump jumped over it
backwards yeah and totally changed the
game yep someone that was look they've
been they've been training that way for
however many decades of jump over or
split jump whatever they were doing to
get over it this was a
brand new thing that people looked at
and go wait a second what is this yeah
that's how different it was to say oh
we're gonna get a hold of this opponent
and we're gonna get a hold of their arm
or we're gonna get a hold of their neck
or we're gonna get a hold of their leg
and we're gonna force them to tap out or
we're gonna break it
people just didn't understand this yeah
all right
uh 1932 at the age of 15 he entered his
first promotional Shiite testing for
Showdown
that's for the first dawn it's a first
degree in tournaments at that time a
candidate often stayed on the mat until
he was defeated Kimura beat five
other high school students and earned
his show Don so he got his first degree
the next year his run-in with his
Elementary School teacher and his vow to
achieve naidon apparently forgotten he
entered the promotional contest again
defeating all four members of the
opposing Team all by it Paul
and was promoted to nidown which is the
second degree so interesting in Judo if
you don't know this itpong is a way that
you can immediately win a judo match by
throwing your opponent where their feet
leave the ground and any part of their
body touches the ground before their
feet if you do that you instantly win
we could discuss the what that really
means because unfortunately
okay if you're on concrete
and you throw someone on concrete it's
definitely gonna hurt them it's going to
hurt them more than a mat is going to
hurt them so you could understand why
people would say well you know if I
threw you like this
I would win so therefore if I throw you
like this in a tournament I will win
that being said
you can get thrown even on concrete and
not be knocked out and not be
injured badly and that's where Jiu Jitsu
comes into play because in Jiu Jitsu you
throw someone that fights far from over
doesn't matter how you throw them you
have to submit them you have to get body
control you have to really
really Dominate and submit them in order
to win so
Leopold again
there are certain if on throws that have
happened on concrete like you're you're
not getting it for sure but there's also
if on throws that wouldn't knock you out
wouldn't wouldn't knock you out wouldn't
disable you from continuing to fight but
those are the rules that's one of the
problems with the rules in fighting
as soon as you put rules in fighting
things change any rule things change
sometimes they don't really matter
sometimes they do really sometimes they
do matter you know one is uh
like for instance in MMA and in Jiu
Jitsu there's there's a rule that says
no small joint manipulation yeah all
that means is I'm not allowed to grab
one of your fingers and bend it and
break it
so let's say I'm trying to choke you
and you and you're not allowed in a jiu
jitsu tournament to grab my finger and
break it you're not allowed to do that
here's why I actually think this is a
legit rule because if you and I were in
a real fight and I I had your back and I
was trying to choke you and you grabbed
my finger to try and break it guess what
I would do
probably be get angry probably I would
just let you break my finger as I choke
you and then I'd kill you yeah yeah so
it's not a game changer but it prevents
injuries so rules like that usually make
sense now look there's gonna be someone
that says yeah but if I broke your
finger you might freak out it's true
true life or death battle though
not happening I you know even happens if
if you know if you and I are training
and I get a heel hook on you
and since we're just training I don't
really crank it
and
so then you get out
and I might say well you know I I didn't
go hard because we weren't in
competition well guess what you also if
we were in competition you might not top
that you might just let the sprain
happen so it's actually it kind of
cancels itself out a little bit
I'm not cranking as hard as I could
you're also not avoiding tapping it or
you know just not gonna tap yeah which
is a different thing so yeah they're
they're all totally useful though in my
opinion I think that all you know
there's a sportsmanship element to to
All Sports obviously and jiu jitsu's
that those are just some of them where
look because in a jiu jitsu tournament
if there was small joint manipulation
you get guys who aren't right Jiu Jitsu
tournament is not life and death so
technically that finger breaking that
finger or whatever might work because
it's not life or death is this guy broke
my finger I'm not gonna compete with a
broken finger you know it's not that
serious to me yeah now I can't you know
do my job for the next four weeks while
I let my finger heal up like all my
homework yeah nothing in real life or
whatever so it's kind of like all right
let's make that a rule because it's
going to vary from person to person you
know and meanwhile hey if you get a hold
of a finger and it's not that serious as
somebody it's like kind of effective you
know it's like because it hurts and you
get someone who's not thinking life or
death boom they're gonna stop and be
like hey my fingers working whatever so
let's make that a rule let's keep it
Sportsmen like you know the heel hook
thing is kind of the same thing just to
like one level lower like in practice
right where and this goes for any
submission really except for chokes
because jokes you can just choke the guy
out it's no harm no foul but like if you
get a Kimura or something like that
something where I like the more flexible
the guy is the more he'll probably be
able to resist it kind of thing and
you're bending this guy's thing or heel
hook or whatever if this guy you're
training with thinks it's like life or
death he's gonna kind of jam himself up
yeah
but it's up to him he can either tap or
whatever or or he can be like yeah and
get out or whatever it's still just
training it's not that serious you know
so it doesn't necessarily have to be a
rule
so you kind of got that going on I think
that kind of goes for most sports too
you know but you do have to be careful
because there are rules of like for
instance in MMA you're not allowed to
kick a downed opponent in the head yeah
right so that means some of these
positions
are changed they're like back in the day
in Pride you could kick in the head and
you could knee in the head I remember I
used to spar with Dean when he's getting
ready for pride and like if I shot on
him and sprawled he'd need me in the
head 17 times like legit yeah he and
it's it's not it's not a good thing yeah
whereas in the UFC you're not allowed to
do that so that means you can shoot you
can get sprawled on and the person has
to adjust their attack and it makes you
it makes shooting a much more
comfortable thing because you think oh
I'll just you know whatever I'll get
back to the top or I'll get back up to
my feet if you know that every time you
shoot and get sprawled on you're gonna
get need in the head nine times that's a
problem they have the thing with that
quote downed opponents so if you and I
are fighting
and you're in a position where you could
knee me but I put my hand on the ground
like Up Against the Cage this happens
like I put my hand on the ground now I'm
a quote down opponent now you're not
allowed to kick or need me in the head
yeah well that's kind of right the rules
are starting to affect the the way a
fight would go yeah what do they call it
game in it yeah you start gaming in the
system that's part of it and that's one
of the things that happens with Judo
another thing in Judo is you can pin
someone
you know so you if you hold someone down
you can win the match that way in Jiu
Jitsu you can't win by pinning look it
sucks being on the bottom when someone's
holding you down but you don't that that
person on top either has to hold you
there until it's over
and hopefully they're up on points or
they have to try and submit you but they
can't finish the fight just by holding
someone so there are rules that
affect and remove some of the realism
from some martial arts you know some of
the point fighting uh striking Arts
where you're you're throwing strikes but
you're actually not allowed
to there's somewhere you're not allowed
to strike in the head so you see guys
come out and they have their hands down
because they're just trying to deal with
body blows which totally messes up their
fighting for real
so you have to be careful with rules
nonetheless
in Judo you win
all right going back to the book The
Following Year may of 1934 he traveled
to Kyoto for the first time in his life
to test for his third degree he was
required to take a written exam and
skill test as well as compete
after passing the skill test he admits
in his autobiography which again I tried
to find to being clueless about the
written exam so he turned around and
snatched the finished exam from the boy
behind him and turned it in
obviously the increasingly serious
Kimura still had some mischievous Boy
Inside in the contest at only age 16 he
was awarded the rank of third degree
he moved up one degree for each of his
three consecutive years next year as a
10th grader about age 15 to 16 Camira
fought in the Saga
prefectural budokudin
red white team match amazingly
uh with only about a year's time in
grade he threw four of the other third
degrees and and other opponents
including the captain of the opposing
team 10 for 10. he was awarded the rank
of yodon which is fourth degree at the
age of 16 after only six years of
training he was named captain of the
chinsei high school team as a junior on
honor use the reserved for a senior now
he's a badass
and not to mention he's trading five
hours a day I mean bro you're training
five hours a day you're not doing
anything in school but just training
you're now look
there is a distinction
between people that train hard people
that are naturally gifted and then
there's a third Group which is people
that are naturally gifted and they train
hard
if you're in that third group you're
rare you're rare human because a lot of
times people that are naturally gifted
they get away they don't even learn how
to train hard they don't even know how
to train hard because they're just so
naturally gifted you get other people
that are that that they they don't have
the gift so they have to train hard so
they learn to train hard and both those
groups actually can become champions
but if you want to become a a goat yeah
you have to Goat if you want to be a
goat you got to be in that third you got
to be George Saint Pierre naturally
gifted and train like a freaking Maniac
yeah right that's what that's what you
become in those situations
so my my suspicion is
that Kimura had
natural talent and train like crazy this
is what you end up with a guy that's
just murdering people when he's 16 years
old
uh a fourth Dawn high school student was
extremely rare and Kimura began to
attract national attention in his senior
year Kimura competed in the National
Junior High School tournament Kyoto his
team Advanced to the finals and he had
and he had to face a very tough team
from Kyoto first commercial Junior High
School a team known for its strong
groundwork nawaza
that's the other thing you gotta
remember is I mean
this stuff that's going on in high
school
you know Judo is the sport in Japan
especially in this time it's kind of you
know when I talk to people from around
the country and people will ask me well
people used to say like oh your son's in
high school or your daughters or you
what sports do they play
and you always say wrestling and then
for my son I'd be like oh my he's on the
surf team
if you're like you know what are you
talking about like oh no they have a uh
yeah he's on the surf team at his high
school
what do you mean well they have a surf
team they compete against other high
schools they have a California state
champion like that's the way it goes
Judo is like that in Japan especially at
this time this was the sport this is
what they're doing you know what's
another cool thing if you're have you
been to Thailand no never in Thailand
Muay Thai it's like the national sport
and if you go to America and you flew
around a town in a helicopter
all the tennis courts all the basketball
courts all the baseball diamonds all the
soccer fields all those things all those
different sports in Thailand the way I
remember it there's only one thing it
was just Muay Thai so you'd be walking
down the street you see like little kids
just throwing Muay Thai kicks at each
other you'd see kids kicking bags like
hanging in instead of having you know if
you drive that through a neighborhood in
San Diego how many basketball hoops do
you see in the neighborhood yeah yeah
you see you know you see 25 houses you
see seven or eight basketball hoops in
the driveway
in Thailand
there's just a heavy bag yeah you
there's that many heavy bags there's no
nothing else
that's pretty legit yeah it's legit yeah
so and I seen you can see videos online
of you know this guy where I remember
Stuart Cooper Stuart Cooper films yeah
he lived in Thailand for a while and you
know you can watch cool videos or
whatever and yeah when you see the yeah
they're out on the streets the same way
and that's such a good comparison where
if you take football basketball baseball
and actually soccer and you put those
all together in the US it's just yeah
because like it's like the old thing
where you know um you know you see kids
just playing basketball with a basket
you know pinned up um or you know guys
just randomly playing soccer in a place
where you don't really play soccer in
the driveway or in the cul-de-sac or
something like that in fact go down
neighborhoods you'll see the basketball
thing basketball basket in the
cul-de-sac for everyone kind of a thing
it's like just kind of we can pick up
here and pick up their whatever it's the
same exact thing but it's the kids
randomly hanging out at the park two
guys doing Muay Thai over here you know
just yeah you guys doing more time over
there's a kid kicking a freaking palm
tree over there yeah
it's crazy and that's what Judo was at
this time
for Japan yeah it was like that's what
we're doing yeah we're doing Judo so him
being a champion it's kind of like being
a surfing
champion in high school in California
you're you're compete do they have surf
teams in Hawaii yeah were you on it no
not not for high school no was I on it
no no
not in high school in fact now I'm
thinking of it they're like clubs
they're not for like high school what
you're talking about no yeah they have a
Scholastic surf program
and you compete yeah well if they do
have it in Hawaii I don't know about it
it's like in the mountains they have ski
teams at high schools you know like
that's just what they're doing what
about snowboarding probably probably but
you know I can't speak for this nobody I
don't know it as well but in New England
growing up like some kids that went to
school in Vermont or New Hampshire they
had little ski teams
so that's really really good for lack of
a better word indoctrination but the
Judo the whole that's why we've covered
the Judo books on here and I forget the
number of the podcast but you know
there's a whole Judo is just not a sport
it's a whole way of being it's a whole
way of acting and that's what they were
trying to inculcate the people with was
a sort of a warrior spirit that was
centered around this martial art
Judo so this guy Kimura just being as
good as he is that's saying a lot
[Music]
um
fast forward he does another contest
there's a bunch of results of contests
in here one time he had a triple Victory
and his school for the first time became
the national champions
he talks about some of those fights here
which is interesting to hear he says I
had two big fights during my chinsei
junior high days in those days Buddha
was widely and feverishly practiced
given this background it was a natural
consequence that a young man who rapidly
became famous became a target of
challenge the first fight occurred when
I was in the second year one member of
chinsei Junior High Judo Club whose name
was Ida
who competed for the position of second
year student Captain with me and lost
developed a hatred toward me
on a Saturday of June on my way to the
school dojo he walked up to me and said
I have a little business with you so
come with me in a case like this the
meaning of business is tactically
understood he uttered you are impudent I
am going to get you today
and took out a jackknife from his pocket
and suddenly thrust it at my abdominal
area I thought I evaded it successfully
but the knife got into my buttock he got
on a bicycle and started to run away I
also ran after him while bleeding from
the buttock and finally got to his house
he stayed inside the house and did not
come out instead his parents came out
and apologized to me thoroughly and
sincerely they said our son cut his own
hand when he stabbed you he is in his
bed now with doctors on the way it
turned out that eda's injury was more
serious than mine but I had to stay away
from practice for about 20 days
so he got caught up
dude back in the day just like that the
Judo players weren't playing no they're
not in my third year at school I was
challenged by K
the name of the student is kept secret
in the book who was then considered to
be the number one Street Fighter among
all the junior high school students in
the area he was a student of Kuma
Kumamoto
Commerce Junior High he was small in
stature but was known to pull out a
knife in every street fight it was known
that when he loses his parents and
relatives all join him and Ambush for
Revenge
on my way back
I was about to cross the bridge he found
me and said hold it right there come
with me we walked to a park near Sunset
he said you are come here aren't you
this was the first time that we saw each
other face to face we glared each other
over a distance of about one meter then
suddenly he pulled out a Tonto which is
a freaking short sword and thrust it
Forward at me I evaded it grabbed them
and threw him hard onto the ground now
in this state he is no match to me
I am K I Surrender you are strong he
honestly revealed his identity and
apologized after this none of his
parents came to see me moreover no
Junior High School student challenged me
for a street fight yeah dude when you
get a sword pulled on you then you just
Jack the dude you're not worried about
getting picked on anymore
the fall of 1934.
um he's now going to Universal
University takushoko
taku Shoku again I apologize to my
Japanese people out there from
mutilating your language
um he's going to college now kamira
defeated eight consecutive opponents
lost his ninth match
although Kimura smoked
as did many Japanese men he reported he
was an excellent long distance Runner
during his college Years Camira said in
a 1987 interview he trained 10 and a
half hours a day he would begin by
striking the Macky War which is like a
striking post a thing that you punch
you've seen those things
throwing the Rope around it one thousand
times with each fist a Training Method
he had learned from studying karate
then he would head off to the police
department Dojo where he would work out
with other tough judoka for about an
hour a three-hour training session at
takudai followed then from 6 30 to about
7 30 p.m he would train at the kodacon
followed by a three-hour session at a
local Judo Dojo near the campus but that
was not the end of his day after I went
home and ate I would I would take a bath
and then do solo training first a
thousand push-ups then bodybuilding 600
bench presses with 80 kg
it's 175 pounds roughly barbells
just that would take about an hour
so he's going that's a Savage workout
yes it is I I I'm thinking about doing
that it's okay I'm thinking about
getting into like dude 600 reps that's
crazy that actually kind of sounds like
your kind of workout you know how like
you you're you I don't know you told me
this couple times a few times where you
I was like oh what was the workout you'd
be like oh yeah pull-ups today and I was
like bro what does that mean like mine
is like four sets of five or five sets
of 12. you're like yeah pull-ups today
how are you doing like I don't know
thousands of pull-ups but it's like over
time right like you just see how and
that's what that sounds like where it's
like yeah 80 80 kilograms grams I'm
gonna do 600. I mean I'll be honest with
you I don't like benching because
because it I don't like the way it feels
on my shoulder so maybe I have to figure
out maybe there's a dumbbell equivalent
or something I don't know maybe hell
yeah dumbbells all day so benching
bench is a good one I feel I feel like I
don't know for sure but I feel like
Arnold kind of was like one of the main
like proponents of bench so it kind of
got like a thing but then again I know
there's like a bench before there was a
guy when I got to the team
and he was an older dude you know
which means he was probably a little bit
younger than me right now but he seemed
a little old at the time but he was he
worked in the paraloft which is where
they they pack parachutes and stuff yeah
and I think he was kind of
you know finishing up his uh finishing
up his career
but he would allegedly he would just
like pack a parachute like do do like
let's say it takes 20 minutes to pack a
parachute he'd pack a parachute for five
minutes get like to a certain step and
then just go Jack steal for 15 minutes
or 10 minutes and come back and do a
little bit more and he would just
basically lift all day long yeah
that's the kind of thing where I think
that'd be real good for you well yeah I
mean all this
so I learned this
phrase when I was kind of getting
certified to be a personal trainer back
in the day dude I kind of forgot about
that time on retention no um you've
quoted that one to me before yeah and
that one goes deep by the way some
people they think like oh let's just put
a lot of tension on there or sorry a lot
of time under tension but that's pretty
low tension if the time is gonna be
anyway no it's not that it's um it was
in regards to
you know in the there's a I don't know
you don't go to public gym so in public
gyms this is the thing I've been to
public gyms yeah so okay okay believe it
or not there you go but you'll be less
familiar with this um this event this
occurrence
where someone will see someone doing
something quote unquote wrong right and
then they're going they'll correct them
correct them or give them tips or
whatever unwanted advice advice exactly
right solicited unsolicited
so you know some guys they do it to
girls to maybe just getting in to talk
to someone there's many different
reasons for it but the main one of the
main like problems that would come from
that sometimes is like when you ask
someone like hey or when you tell
someone hey no that you're doing it
wrong here's the right way to do it no
matter how nice you say it the thing
you're missing is what are they training
for so really one of the things you have
to understand is you have to know what
the person is training for to be able to
determine if they're doing it right or
wrong for the most part there are
exceptions but then are you training to
blow out your back
hey man like I said like so and there
are so many times where even as a
professional trainer for decades or
whatever you find out what they're
training for and you're like oh wait a
minute that makes a lot more sense I
don't know about that kind of training
that's like some Fitness routine and or
or competition or whatever you're doing
is that I'm unfamiliar with and you have
to admit that obviously so you can be
surprised with that stuff where you're
thinking that violates every rule that
I've ever learned ever in a
certification course or outside of a
certification course that violates it
you go find out what they're trying
training for you like I never heard of
that so I I have nothing to input on
your training you know
anyway
um so you gotta like I said back to the
point you gotta find out what they're
training for so you know how you say you
just said
that sounds like it'd be good for you
yeah yeah maybe yeah I mean if you're
gonna be getting in 40 minute Judo
matches
and you can bench press that takes you
an hour I mean if he said that took
about an hour
dude that's a lot that's 10 reps a
minute you know for an hour yeah so
there's um that's a freaking tough
workout man so the because there's
certain physiological and biological
like things that go on in your body if
you train certain ways you know so
um and the Bulgarian if you look into
the bulgarians yeah that's crazy so they
they do stuff like um
they just max out it'd be like an
eight-hour training sesh all max out but
they'd max out like at a certain time
you know
so the rep the volume would be like kind
of small but the intensity would be just
the highest doubles and singles oh yeah
and there's all kinds of ways to do that
um so depends like I said depends on
what you're training for depends on the
approach because there are many ways to
get that to that goal depending on the
person depends on like what kind of
change regardless of everything that
you're saying right now sir yeah let's
face it if you can bench press 185
pounds 600 times yeah in an hour
let's face it regardless of whatever
you're saying you're in pretty good
shape that's a good training good
training so what and then but then but
think about this and you know and I'm
not just being a contrarian at all but
it's something to think about where
bench dumbbell press whatever that's
usually for like power lifting or
bodybuilding right so if you're training
for like to be able to endure some
punishment and still have your muscles
and Joints function so that's why you're
doing that training I could see it for
sure but it goes above it goes beyond
like bodybuilding because he said
bodybuilding but it goes it's not the
best way maybe he means bodybuilding not
in the way that you're thinking yeah it
doesn't mean bodybuilding like I'm gonna
be on the cover of a magazine he means
I'm building my body for war yeah I
think you're correct about them
uh he then goes going back to the book
this is his him talking about his
training routine then
uchikomi which is practicing throwing
without a partner against a maple tree a
thousand times I would rapid judo belt
around a very thick maple tree
but doing that a thousand times
a day the trees would snap rather
quickly it was really expensive
then I would take out a rope and do
those sotogari training so this guy is
training like a madman kamira told the
same interview that he slept only about
two hours a night feeling that sleep was
a waste of time no wonder he trained no
wonder he gained a reputation as the
training ogre or training demon so
uh
he ended up having some losses
um one time a guy named osawa kenichiro
threw Camira head first onto the mat
game of concussion
despite his concussion he fought another
match this time against Abe
kenshiro Abe was another Judo Prodigy
uh youngest ever some of his
advancements and he lost he or he also
beat Kimura
had another loss by Yamamoto ideo
so he had some losses
and of course
it says this in the book Chimera was
extremely except upset by the unusual
experience of losing and reportedly
considered quitting Judo for a time oh
that's that day when you go to the Jiu
Jitsu match and you think man this isn't
for me that's I actually that's actually
a overused joke of mine you know like if
I have a rough day on the matter like
man I walked out of here yesterday I was
about thinking maybe I just need to give
up Jiu Jitsu yeah yeah but that's how
though right remember like how you did
you have a word for I think you might be
talking about something else but we've
got the guys in the teams who were there
like so good at stump something and
they've never lost and they don't really
lose so when they're losing devastates
them way worse than the average oh this
isn't the Seal team this is going
through buds yeah like a guy going
through Buzz who's a gazelle gazelle
meaning they always win they want
everything their whole life they're
never lost anything and then they just
yeah devastating yeah they can't handle
it can't handle the pressure oh so is
that you you feel like there was some
gazelle like qualities in that scenario
for um for Kimura nope I don't think so
I think that he had won a bunch
okay a little bit that was like a Jocko
okay that was like a little like
what were you saying about squats where
you're like I think it's what the 20
reps question yeah I don't even want to
be strong I didn't know if I want to be
strong I'd rather just be weak just get
me out of here Jessica's like the 20
reps are so daunting you're like
questioning your whole uh strength those
those squats when you do those 20 rep
squats for real when you do them for
real they're they're they're they're a
Journey a mental Journey now we've had
people on the podcast talking about
their uh psychedelic Journeys with like
Ayahuasca and all this stuff and they're
screaming and crying and like their
insides are burning and all this stuff
if you do 20 reps squats correctly same
thing bro do you just do one giant set
or or one like hard set or is it like
like two three how many sets do you do
over the 20s when I was really into that
well I I have this where it's actually
in the book discipline equals freedom
field manual
I
I haven't done this in a long time and I
would need to like change my lifestyle a
little bit again and get back in the
game on that particular game so I used
to do
warm up and then I would do
20 rep squat 20 minute break 20 minute
squat or 20 rep squat 20 minute break
20 rep squats so we take one hour yeah
and it'll be 20 minutes of recovery
it was horrible it was so I Would by the
time I got done like I would take you
know get done go for a jog to try and
move some of the lactic acid and
by the time I got done I would be
thinking like I have to do this again in
whatever it is five days and I'd be like
upset about it yeah I'd be thinking
maybe I should get into crochet maybe I
should get into like some other thing
what's funny about that I can relate 100
by the way but what's funny about that
especially when you're like freaking
like you're so mad that you have to do
it you know what's your workout you made
it up you don't have to do anything you
know but it's like you're so like
connected to the workout it's like 20
rep squats if you only got 19 reps like
you'll probably be mentally kind of
jammed up for a little bit oh yeah bro I
have that too that's weird the and this
is fresh in my mind about the 20 rep
squat so I've never done the 20 rep
squats like that I've done 20 reps with
a weight that you can only do yeah like
as the workout I've done 15 and actually
I did 15 today but here's the thing it's
not it's different so I did my regular
squat routine and then I just put a
light weight on there and I did 15 but
this is at the end and I try to keep my
rest to kind of a minimum so I'm like
kind of like jammed up so I was like let
me let me bust out 15 real quick my legs
are burning right now they're weaker you
know you're like weaker
and I went and my usual higher rep is
12. that's my usual higher rep day so
once I hit the 12 I could just feel my
body just like strength just drop off
13. yeah like almost like
physiologically it thought it was done
like for real so at 13 it was like
almost like the thing got so heavy all
of a sudden then I did 14 and then like
the 15th it was kind of that like you
said that almost like an outer body
experience kind of like hey your legs
kind of don't really work anymore look
it was lighter weight so I get it but I
could feel the little hints of this
where like your legs don't work anymore
like hey like your legs are saying hey
we're not supposed to be doing this and
they check out so you're just like using
your whole brain to get like the rep or
whatever I'm like dang what if I had to
do any of those things even with that
weight right there but I think I think
that might take me off to a distant land
yeah yeah you got to get used to that
you do you do I saw freaking uh uh Josh
hanger right you know that is right
joshinger he's uh he trains at Otto's
guys yeah yeah yeah
so he it was like just a video clip that
he posted or whatever he was like oh
yeah
um finishing out the my leg workout with
a set of 20 and it was two wheels 225
and he did all twinning I was like bro
and he's smaller than me I was like bro
you got me beat by a lot Hawaiian that
is some uh
so
that being said we're talking about this
quitter's mindset that can come in and
it came to Kimura and he's he lost a few
times lost four times and he says maybe
I should just quit but then going back
to the book his competitive personality
and the encouragement of several friends
led him to rededicate himself he's to
train even harder
at the University he trained to increase
his strength by carrying around 132
pound bag of sand
he said I thought practicing twice as
much as others would be sufficient since
I heard others were practicing about
three hours a day in reality however
they had been practicing about four
hours a day which I found out later
he gets revenge
there's a section called revenge osawa
cangenero or kenoshiro one of those who
had defeated Kimura in competition
regularly trained at the keishu police
dojo and Kimura exacted his revenge on
osawa there
throwing him for epon
Abe kenshiro was more difficult to catch
up with because their paths seldom
crossed but Kimura caught wind of the
fact that Abe was going to be training
at the Koda Con on a certain day and
showed up to challenge him
500 Matt Dojo was silent except for the
two judoka during the 20-minute practice
Abe was thrown many times
chimura threw Abe to the hardwood floor
presumably off the edge of the mat 11
times and six times to the tatami
disgusted Abe eventually quit
at the time Kimura was still a college
student while Abid graduated and was a
professional instructor
so he got his little Vengeance those
were in the training Hall but it sounds
like if you're in the training Hall
and everyone stops and watches you you
know what I mean like it's one thing
like oh let's say you and I had we know
you'd beat me in a tournament and then I
went to your Academy and I beat you or
you came to Maya or whatever we met at a
neutral Academy just in a training
session like an open map and then I beat
you I wouldn't feel like I really got my
Vengeance yeah but if everybody stopped
and they were watching and then I threw
you 11 times onto the hardwood yeah
I'd be like yeah you know what's up now
yeah there's a little bit of Revenge oh
yeah and especially and that's a good
point too when everyone stops and
watches right where I mean there's
there's a few subtle elements that are
sometimes most of the time like they're
intangible only the two people
that are competing or practicing feel it
where you know like
when things escalate and you feel the
sense of training start to diminish in
the sense of competition really take
over you know like We'll add that before
come on SO with a scenario like this
where it's like hey you beat me in the
tournament and then you start feeling
that bubble up and then people start
watching that's when you know that's
like 100 like hey this is no longer
training this it's on this is the
rematch going on right now I feel like
that's the case okay you don't feel that
way no I think you're right I think when
you have a bunch of when you have a 500
mat that's a huge Dojo it's a code man
it's a massive place and everyone's
watching
feel that escalator and you're getting
smashed like however many times in a row
yeah
imagine being that much of a champion
like Abe was and somebody comes and just
beats you whatever 17 times
that's humiliation yeah that's rough
that's real rough
in the fall of 1937 Kimura repeated his
victory as all Japan Collegiate champion
in the bi-annual Tournament winning six
matches
three with a sotogari one with their paw
one with his increasingly famous arm
lock and one by pin as a result of this
win Kimura became the first student
permitted to enter the all Japan Judo
Championship
held October 23rd and 24th 1937.
in the finals
he goes against a guy Nakajima
mazayuki who's a fifth Don
he got these there's a really good and
hey I'm just reading little excerpts of
this book obviously get the book get the
book Christopher M Clarke I don't think
I mentioned his uh name yet but that's
the book it's Christopher M Clarke who
wrote the book get the book it's on
Amazon
uh I'm only reading some highlights from
it so if you want the details get it but
he goes into a pretty good description
of how he of of this competition
but uh
let me let me take you through what he
says
he says after
after the 30-minute battle both my skin
and ghee were soaked with sweat sweat
was Dripping in so much quantity that I
could hardly open my eyes I had to open
my eyes alternately to see
for the next overtime
I and Nakajima sat
to bring our ghee to the proper position
I tried to untie the belt but I could
not generate enough force in my hands to
do so the knot felt as hard as a stone
my fingers were almost completely
powerless so that it took me a long time
to fix the ghee
then I saw Nakajima extend his legs
alternately rub his calfs with his hands
I thought those legs are the key for my
victory
I re-tightened my black belt and watched
his motion carefully as soon as the
judge announced start I tackled at his
legs he fell on his buttocks I then
caught him
thinking I could never win if I lost
this chance and frantically held him
pinned
the intense battle which lasted 40
minutes finally ended
so
that's kind of crazy
um there's another in preparing for that
match
and I and I read an interview with him
as well but he has like a
basically it's it's a near-death
experience
that he has it says this in the book
Kimura constantly pushed himself to find
his limits in 1936 while training for
the national championships he had what
he called a mysterious experience in
which I truly discarded my life
so he goes to this um other dojo and
they actually had an actually mihan and
I were talking about this Miha pointed
out that they have something called
which is practice outside one's regular
Dojo which is really smart it's really
smart not just to only TR look it's good
to have it's great to have a great
school that you train at but it's also
good to go and try other go to other
gyms and this is for anything you know
in in the seagull teams like when I ran
training we had Rangers that came and
worked with us we had special forces
guys that came hey how do you guys do we
would send guys to their schools why
because we want to practice outside of
our own dojo we want to get the other
look yeah you know that's kind of a term
that gets used these days get another
look
so that's actually how I met Miha cause
me I was coming you know some of the
guys from Legion come down here you know
like let's mix it up
you know that they're on a Open Mat day
at Victory there's people from every
basically every Academy in Southern
California really so
that's a good plan so that's what Kimura
does in this particular instance and he
says I went to train and there were
about 82 students there
all of whom who were un under who had
been undergoing strenuous training they
were strong back then we were we're
talking about an instructor's College
I said
and he asked the way of asking the
trainees to engage in practice I'm not
going to try and use the Japanese to
have it in here
and step down to the dojo so he
basically says hey who wants to train
and he says it in a friendly way
and he stepped in for a type of training
that's called continuous attack practice
which to me kind of sounds like what we
might call a Shark Tank song yes sir
he says I had won the student
Championship so when I threw one of them
the next would charge at me and I try to
hang on and go all out to throw him I
thought that even if I went to my knees
I would get the hip on I'd do about five
minutes with one person for around 70
people
at some point I began to feel faint and
when I braced myself against it I lost
Consciousness and fell forward however
my body was moving even though I lost
Consciousness the offense and defensive
techniques kept on fighting for me
I don't know where I went then when I
looked about 15 students of the
instructors College were gathered
together looking at something in one
corner of the dojo I wondered what they
were doing
while I was training
and when I glanced over I saw somebody
stretched out on the floor when I looked
down from above I said hey isn't that me
when I looked at my face stretched out
on the floor
it looked calm and peaceful
I was smiling as I slept
I felt that this was a really good way
to sleep
so strenuous was the practice that even
Kimura felt he was dying
heart beating so fast he thought his
heart was going to explode however he
held on and gradually regained his
strength and mental power back through
this experience he realized that no
matter how exhausted he would eventually
regain his power back this belief was
one of the reasons for kimura's
unbelievable victories
taking it to the Limit as we like to say
crazy
have an out-of-body experience
he's on the Ayahuasca DMT camera
Jiu Jitsu man it feels so good when that
happens look I have a I don't
other than being knocked out or choked
out unconscious in both those categories
where you have an out of body experience
which I've definitely had both those
but to push yourself
and that hard in training like I've
never done that but every time you go
hard in training man you feel good when
you're done and there's something
there's something about Jiu Jitsu I must
say
that's better than normal like let's say
you and I were like hey let's go do a
Sprint workout let's go do a Mac Con
like let's do something that's so super
hardcore
that doesn't feel the same there's not
the same goodness yeah
am I wrong you're uh you're really right
now so in in
oddly and coincidentally recently this
was part of my like rabbit hole thought
process as well like why is that right
where it's like okay you could say in
which I I think I would agree with where
it's like
when you're kind of especially as a male
um human being you you battling against
like another male is like kind of like
there's a a payoff on top of the payoff
with that kind of exercise or whatever
sure I think that's true
but after a while I was thinking like
hey I think I think it's this I think
like you know how like you
when you're really good friends with
someone and it's kind of like oh I could
be doing this thing but if my friend was
here with me we could do it together and
we could like share in the fun times and
whatever and then when you think of that
long term when you have like a really
good friend you share in the fun times
and the junk times then you come back to
normal and you can go you can hey
remember that time where this fit and it
really sucked and we but you guys went
through it together shared sufferings
this shared suffering exactly right so
now you have a combination of and I
think some some in some weird way I feel
like this is kind of part of the purpose
of life I think where you have that
shared suffering and it's concentrated
it's really concentrated shared
suffering
shared Joy exercise and everything that
that comes with because it's not like
normal exercise think about like how
hard 10 rounds is because we did 10
Rounds earlier I only did eight but
the last eight is still you know
something think of think how hard that
is as far as output goes like if you had
one of those monitors or whatever like
think about it like to replicate a
workout like that within that amount of
time which is like you know you figure
they're five minute rounds what 45 I
don't know how long in between but
consider the whole time frame yeah
and then the output that is a hard
workout then you know what else is cool
is you get done with a jiu jitsu workout
you know that no matter what level
you're at even if you're a white belt
and you're on your third month
and you train hard
you know
that you can now beat
basically anyone that wasn't in there
with you that day you know what I mean
like okay executing all the Jitsu people
obviously because you're only a white
belt you only been training for three
months but that's a small number when
you talk about the population of Earth
yeah so you get you get that thing where
you're like like even the other day Okay
we did a bunch of rounds with a bunch of
really good people
just being there on that map means that
there's most people on planet Earth you
can actually take right they were not on
them they were not on that map yeah and
yeah and that yeah that goes with like
kind of what I was saying earlier where
like you know like that just what that
entails and what that kind of delivers
to you that's part of like the whole Joy
of like especially afterwards when
everything is settled right that's one
of the things that got delivered to you
but the part where you kind of connect
with another guy in the in that way
where
like me and you were straight up going
to battle it's a proxy for a battle but
we did like as far as our brains are
concerned we kind of did
so we had the shared suffering we had
all that stuff and then we opposed each
other and at the end we sort of made up
right we're no longer enemies anymore
and let's face it when you when you
battle with a guy super hard like in
like in real life like you hate each
other or whatever as a kid and you hate
each other and then at the end of the
day you're kind of like wait a second
we're kind of the same and then you
become friends with them I feel like
that's kind of a natural part of
existence as well so I think you get a
some kind of a payoff deep down I think
you get some sort of sort of a payoff
generally speaking with that rule right
so I feel like all of those elements all
mixed together in one experience the
Jujitsu experience I think that's why it
feels so good there's a weird dichotomy
so the when in ramadi we worked with
this
Battalion of soldiers called the first
of the 506 red curry
I hear the Band of Brothers best you
know awesome guys
and they had a little saying
that was
We Stand Alone Together
um
so that's kind of what happens when you
Jitsu like you're alone together yeah so
kind of a cool thing and you um
think about when you roll with a guy who
you've never met before and you roll
with them and you guys have a solid
sacrum no matter who gets who or who
doesn't or tie or what it doesn't matter
the outcome but you have a sick role
with them you kind of feel connected to
them oh for sure you see that guy the
next week like at the store yeah bro
you're way better friends than if he was
in your class in college or something
like that getting the groceries out to
the car and whatnot well freaking you
guys are kind of friends like you jump
levels in the relationship with one role
um
so he wins this National Championship
right he's the all Japan national uh
champion
he says he couldn't sleep for excitement
despite exhausting two days of
competition he did 500 push-ups and a
kilometer of bunny hops
but kamira still didn't sleep well as he
laid down in bed he said to himself
today's victory was a fluke I had more
stomach stamina than Nakajima simply
because I'm younger than he is could I
beat him again probably not I would lose
next time
this is like Obsession leveling before
the tournament kamira's goal had been
merely to win the National Championship
now however he decided he wanted to
remain undefeated Champion for 10 years
he realized that to accomplish this goal
he would have to redouble his efforts
and train harder than anyone else
possibly could mulling over his goal he
finally came up with what he called
triple effort training regimes
as he later told it I am the champion
others would start to train six hours a
day to beat me I could not beat them as
long as I trained
as hard as others
five opponents trained twice as hard as
others then I will train three times as
hard as others I.E 9 hours a day this
way I would gain an extra three hours a
day and I will do this every day the
accumulation of these extra hours will
become my flesh and blood that is my
skills and my mental power
that's what he's doing when's the
national championship and realize he's
going to train three times harder than
anybody else
all this physical activity gave Kimura a
monstrous appetite the 91 the 1937
championships he reportedly celebrated
by eating 13 bowls of rice during his
prime meet seven to eight bowls of rice
in the morning 12 bowls of rice in the
evening plus some fish such as red
snapper and iwashi
which is sardines this dude's grubbing
down fishing right
kimura's principal coach during his
prime competing years was
ushijima
tatsukuma
ushijima's teaching was as ferocious as
his own training according to hirano
training under ushima ushi ushijima was
hell training a class consisted of five
minutes of warm-ups followed by three to
four hours of nothing but continuous
nawaza which is interesting to hear
Nawaz is what we do in Jiu Jitsu is just
rolling basically it was considered
disgraceful to tap out and surrender
when being choked so at any time four or
five students were likely to be lying
unconscious on the tatami as others
continued to practice around them
yeah behind I were laughing about that
one like there's just bodies dude
there's just bodies on the map you know
and hey five minute warm-up then four
hours of nawaza four hours of training I
like that
ushijima's teaching was tough was this
tough
psychologically as it was physically his
model reported reportedly was attacked
till your heart stops beating
he had no patience for
self-congratulations or excuses after
chimura won eight matches in a row and
received his godan at the 1934 Koda Khan
competition he went back to ushijima to
proudly show his accomplishments rather
than praise him for his victories
however ushijima slapped his face
repeatedly telling him that competition
is equivalent to a real sword
kill or get killed duel between bushy
Warriors to throw an opponent means to
kill him being thrown means being killed
you killed eight men you got killed by
the ninth man remember if you devote
your life to Judo you can only Survive
by throwing your opponents or fighting
to a draw no matter how many tough
opponents you face so ferocious was
ushijima's desire to win that in one
famous match he won a tournament because
he he will because in the end he was
able to secure his opponent while
controlling him using his jaws and teeth
to hold him by the belt
that was the true Spirit of jujitsu Judo
that ushijima and Kimura lived by as
historian John Stevens recounts the
style ushijima had trained in was quote
extreme there was no such thing as a
draw the match went on until one of the
competitors gave up or died
some matches were fought with a wooden
dagger kept in one's belt if you pinned
your opponent you could mimic cutting
off his head with the dagger ushijima's
Judo was the same attack attack attack
ushijima visited every Dojo he could
find to engage anyone who was willing to
rent in willing and randori and spent
much of his nights lifting heavy
Boulders and striking trees with his
hands to Bear to build strength
the night before a match he drank
turtle's blood
on the morning of the match he ate
powder made from the body of a poison
Adder he would seclude himself in a cave
for a week doing zazen and reading
Musashi's book of five rings he nearly
trained himself to death developing a
life-threatening viral infection that
ended his career ushijima retired from
competition in 1934 thereafter devoting
himself to making chimura's the world's
top fighter
so there you go I mean
no slack
having overcome his four losses in
adopting a ferocious training program
Kimura went on to win tournament after
tournament
he's the champion from 1938 to 1941.
um
talking about that triple effort
training soon after Kimura started his
triple effort training rumors began to
circulate about how his Rivals were
stepping up in their training and this
is what Kimura has to say initially I
listened to this information with
confidence thinking I will never lose
since I've been training more than nine
hours a day however after a while I
started to doubt my self-confidence in
those days I was interested in Zen I
wanted to reach the state of no ego
discover secret Judo techniques and
throw around tough opponents using the
techniques but in reality I missed a
chance to go to a Zen temple one after
another that is because it was evident
that I would lose my precious time for
training by doing so after all humans
are weak
when they get sick or get into trouble
they depend on God I was no exception I
meditated trying to reach the state of
no ego I first struggled to reach the
state of no ego but I soon lost the
force for struggling and forgot about
tomorrow's bout and the fact that I was
sitting soon after reaching the state
the character win appeared in my mind
actually says appeared on my mind but
the character soon got superimposed on
the character of loss however my mind
was already empty I did not make any
effort to get the character of win I
don't know how much time has elapsed
since I started to sit suddenly my whole
body became hot as if somebody poured
boiling water over me from the top of my
head and my body started to tremble then
I noticed the character of win was
shining at the center of my forehead as
if it had been waiting for me to notice
its appearance
I will win tomorrow's bouts I was
convinced of my victory with pleasure I
believe that it was a message from God
that can only be given to those who
pushed to the maximum limit of mental
and physical strength and get to the
broader get to the border between life
and death if I had pursued only pleasure
I would have seen the character of loss
God sides with only those who challenge
a difficult task despite the possibility
of death
even though I'd wished even though I
even though I had no special belief in
any religion it was my interpretation of
the existence of God
I then calmed down for my joyful feeling
of Victory turned on the light of the
room and prayed for the protection from
various Gods I also prayed to the
ancestors of the Kimura family centuries
ago it is said that Musashi Miyamoto who
was called the greatest swords master
swordmaster in history visited a shrine
before his battle with the yoshika
yoshika family and tried to pull a bell
uttering God please protect me but
remained but regained his calmness and
did not ring the bell
I do not count on gods it was his motto
I thought if I lived the same era of
Musashi pursued the way of the sword and
even fought Musashi I would never lose
at worst
the fight would go even
so there you go some meditation going on
digging deep
um here's a little section I had to talk
about because Echo Charles it's called
Kimura weightlifter ahead of his time
a few Japanese martial artists in the
first half of the 20th century engaged
in systematic
strength or weightlifting training some
utilized old school methods such as
chimura's carrying around a bag of heavy
sand it was not until the late 1950s and
early 1960s when American martial artist
Don Draeger
began to introduce Western weightlifting
and strength training methods to that
such exercise became became commonplace
among judoka
Kimura was decades ahead of it this time
however as early as his college Years in
the mid-1930s Kimura had became a
devoted weightlifter a method that
contributed significantly to his ability
to overpower his opponents albeit with
excellent technique
in his prime chimura did hundreds of
push-ups and other strength exercises
but he supplemented them with bench
presses overhead presses and other
weight training exercises although the
photo on the next page shows him
benching a substantial amount apparently
more than 300 pounds he mostly focused
on high repetitions with moderate weight
according to his own account
he would perform 500 to 600 repetitions
a bench with 175 pounds
an astonishing feat of endurance and
strength so this is like you know kind
of his gig yeah
amazingly Kimura had Chimera made all
the foregoing accomplishments before
graduating from college that's
incredible but while he was attending
takudai and tearing and tearing up the
Judo to Tommy the broader world was
closing in since 1937 Japan had been
engaged in a near full-scale war with
China and many of Japan's young men were
being drafted in the service after
kimura's graduation in March 1941 he was
kept on as an assistant martial arts
Department of
takudai as a judo teacher he worked in
that capacity until November when he
resigned and took two months to go home
before his military induction in January
1942 entering the amkai air defense unit
on January 1st 1942 Chimera apparently
was involved in defending Japan's
Southern sector he recounts a
fascinating story incident that may have
indirectly saved his life and he says
this
one day there was an announcement
that a master of Duke and dough was to
come to our unit his name was y
note the name is kept Anonymous who is
regarded as the number one in Japan and
was eighth Don
all the members in the unit got together
in the field at 1pm to receive
instruction from Mr y he explained the
basics of thrust and defense he then
looked around us and said any volunteer
for practice with me come forward
without any reservation
but nobody came forward
if I engaged in a match with such a
master I would get humiliated or could
get killed men around me whispered
suddenly the captain called my name
now I cannot Retreat I walked with the
master slowly as slowly as possible to
buy time and come up with a workable
strategy if I engage in a bayonet combat
there is no way I can win
if I would it would be like a fight
between an adult and a child since I had
never held a wooden gun in my life we
bowed to each other and held the wooden
gun toward each other I tensed up the
instructor said thrust thrust come on
what's the matter
I knew I would lose as soon as I thrust
the gun at him so I waited for the right
moment for attack I fainted a Thrust
then threw the wooden gun in his face
with full force at the moment he
deflected the wooden gun I attacked at
his knees he fell to the ground I
mounted the chest removed his face guard
despite his shouting weight weight and
tried to deliver finishing blow to his
face stop stop it's over the captain
stepped in and separated us but it was
clear that I had won the fight the
master looked as if he did not
understand what had happened to him
dropped his head and left the scene
there's a classic there's no left damn
just left the scene and That's a classic
you ever done that before what like you
know somebody's got a stick somebody's
got a bit you know someone's got
something they're gonna they're gonna
fight you
and you just close the distance no
I don't think of no yeah it's one of
those things where you're like
it's one of those hey you know the dog
Brothers right yeah yeah so the dog
Brothers the dog Brothers nothing but
awesomeness like these guys were up in
the LA area
I don't know what they're doing right
now I have to look into it but the dog
brothers would do weapons fighting
like go check out their YouTube videos
of dog Brothers the dog brothers would
fight with weapons they'd fight with
sticks primarily started with sticks but
then you see people in there with chains
and with all kinds of crazy stuff and
they'd wear like a Kenpo helmet usually
and maybe they'd wear lacrosse gloves
so you wouldn't get like broken fingers
which we talked about
but other than that it was on so you'd
have you'd have two guys with sticks
or staffs or nunchucks like legit then
they would fight each other man chains
like it's Mayhem
well there's some videos where people
are Jiu Jitsu guys
and what the Jiu Jitsu guys would do is
kind of what this says just
you know throw a stick at him and then
just bum rush them and close the
distance because once you're on somebody
they're they're striking isn't going to
work anymore yeah
so that's this is a good plan if you're
if you're a Grappler you don't want to
you don't want to fight someone you know
with a Bayonet that's trained with
bayonet you don't want to fight a boxer
that's trained in boxing you want to
train a Muay Thai guy that's trying to
Mai Tai you want to close the distance
you want to get it close to them so
their striking doesn't work or run away
that's what Kimura did
you see needless to say Kimura was
was sure he was going to catch hell from
the captain this is after the guy ran
away but the effect was quite the
opposite not long afterward an
announcement was made that those who
wish to be sent to combat should see the
captain chimura volunteered and was
given a five-day leave to visit his
parents when he returned he reported to
the captain who said I have known about
your achievements in Judo I like Judo
too and often practice in the codeacon
compared with you I must be like a kid
but I still got the fourth down
he poured whiskey into a glass continued
the match you did with the jukindo
jukendo master was very interesting
first nobody stepped forward I knew
nobody had a chance against him since he
was the best master in the country
but if nobody volunteered the Dignity of
our unit would be tarnished so even
though I thought I would be discourteous
to you I picked you
but once the match started I got badly
shaken when I saw your posture since you
looked like a complete novice yes that
is right I had never grabbed a wooden
gun before
I thought so but I did not even imagine
the tactics you used I felt like bowing
to you thinking after all a man who
excels in one art is different from
others after the match Mr y came to me
and asked who in the world is he I then
told him about your achievements he was
deeply impressed saying no wonder he's
the number one Judo master in the world
the captain then paused and turned his
eyes downwards engaging in thought he
continued
this is super top secret
so do not tell us to anyone he lowered
his voice tone and said do you really
want to go to the battlefield
yes absolutely
really but that's a problem I had no
idea what the problem was you will be
sent to the Solomon Islands he said it
is certain that b-29s b-29s will be
waiting for our unit our plan is
absolutely Reckless all the members on
board will perish in the ocean
don't you think it's better to use your
talent in Judo and work for the benefit
of the country instead of wasting your
life on the battlefield
I think that is the right thing for you
do you still want to go to the
battlefield I replied yes I do
suddenly his tone of voice changed my
order is the emperor's order you are not
allowed to go
after all
it became an order
I had to follow his order
I said I will withdraw my volunteer
application he then murmured very good
very good
later on I heard that the transportation
ship unit I was going to get on board
was discovered by b-29s immediately
before reaching the Solomon Islands had
oil scattered over the entire deck
received numerous bombs and was engulfed
in flames of over 500 and several tens
of members only one of them survived and
managed to swim to a nearby Island
despite a severe burn in retrospect I
owe my life to the captain Judo moved
him and saved my life
Kimura stayed for the rest of his Tour
on the Mainland Japan
apparently transferred to a post near
asakura
his home Island in southern Japan
although he was in the Army he
reportedly was allowed to teach Judo
once a week at the high school
kimira was known as a heavy drinker
as well as smoker and according to One
account showed up at the school one day
after drinking excessive amount of sake
he was holding a class on nawaza
after demonstrating the choke holds he
called on the students to try them out
on him although Camille was extremely
strong and had a neck like a bull he was
choked into unconsciousness by one of
the students as a result of his
intoxication there's no evidence that
this experience reformed his drinking
happens but it must have been at least
mildly embarrassing for the national
Judo Champion to have been choked out by
a mere high school kid
he's on that sauce it's very strange you
know you just the alcohol is so strong
you know this guy's got to know that
it's not helping his Judo career
remember we were talking about addictive
personalities yeah sounds like he's in
the game
I mean nine hours of training a day that
sounds like it might be addictive
personality alcohol is just one of the
many he's smoking cigarettes smoking
cigarettes
Kimura got married on July 1st 1945 even
as Japan Was preparing to face Invasion
by the increasingly Victorious Allied
armies and navies to fast forward here
the war is over the occupation
authorities closed down the Bhutto kutai
the headquarters for all martial arts
and banned the practice of Judo Kendo
and other militaristic endeavors
shut it down
he says here fast forward a little bit I
was standing at the end of a line of 60
or 70 people waiting for a train
and was reading a paperback suddenly for
MP this military police there's the
occupation forces Men passed through the
line nearby me forcibly when I turned my
eyes to them I found them shouting
jab repeatedly one of them grabbed the
Japanese man at the front of the line by
the caller pulled the man toward him and
made made a ring with the pointing
finger and thumb and stuck the nose the
Japanese man with the flipped pointing
finger with full force the man covered
his nose with his hands and stooped down
from the pain
the MP did this to the MP men did this
to everyone in the line one by one
including women
when someone did not stoop low they
delivered another strike
my turn was approaching while I was
wondering about what to do my turn came
one of the MP men extended his arm
trying to grab my lapel I struck his
hand with full force the facial
expression changed suddenly the four MP
men surrounded me and took me to the
middle of a bridge nearby the station
this was not an ordinary fight to me I
had to win this fight to defend the
honor of Judo one of them came suddenly
and threw a right straight at my face I
blocked the punch with my left arm and
kicked him in the groin with full force
he crumpled on the spot when I turned
back my head another huge MP extended
his arms and attacked me trying to grab
me from behind I then hit his right arm
with a hard knife hand and threw him
into the river
there were two the other two were
watching the scene in amazement but
charged at me only one by one I
delivered a headbutt into the face of
the third man he was knocked out I
disposed to The Last Man by squeaking
squeezing his balls with full force
ever since I was in junior high I have
been called Master groin squeezer and
had an absolute confidence in this
technique
I had asked all the audience to keep it
quiet since I would be in big trouble if
news got to the MP supervisors but
somebody must have leaked the news I
started to regret what I had done but my
concern turned out to be unnecessary
when I got to the MP headquarters
Captain Shepard said thank you for
punishing the Rogue MPS they are the
worst ones in our unit they've sexually
assaulted women ate and drank without
paying threatened people with a pistol
we were about to be forced to punish
them
they are also depressed after you beat
them up I'm truly thankful to you I
heard that you are the greatest Judo
master in Japan I have a request to you
could you teach us Judo once or twice a
week of course I will pay you I myself
am
anxious to learn Judo
so that's how he kind of starts bringing
it back
that's a scene out of a movie though huh
yep just kicking four guys's ass but you
can see how it's happening again this
isn't a time where like you know these
guys what a couple MPS four MPS did one
of those guys wrestle apparently not
did the one of those guys box apparently
not if they're just random dudes and
you're talking about
yeah a dude that's bench pressing uh
175 pounds 600 times an hour and he
trains you out Judo nine hours a day
yeah this is a skilled world champion
world champion borderline unbeatable
human being yeah
that's when you see a movie and a guy
takes on four people you're kind of like
ah you know but if you put in the light
of this actual human
yeah we're nodding in agreement and
you're talking about like a judo guy
right where it's not like a like a you
know I mean no disrespect to the Aikido
but like you know let's say if it's
Aikido guys like it's different you know
Judo guy training that hard for real
Judo for that long that effective that
successful against an untrained guy just
one-on-one this guy literally is like
one of the easiest things to defeat as a
person it's like super easy right then
you got four of them it's actually not
that much of a factor I mean sure you're
gonna take some this a hit here and
there or whatever but
his training is harder than probably
anything they could do to him as far as
like hitting them or whatever just one
training session is way harder way more
uh adverse and they're used to beating
people up oh yeah you know they're not
used to any aggression whatsoever so
they don't even have the idea to like
gang tackle this guy they can't even get
their mind right yeah they're just even
two of them are watching this happen you
know what I mean
yeah that to me is very very very
believable and they're surprised as
they're watching you've seen guys
getting their asses kicked see a guy get
thrown into the river yeah you're like
what the hell just happened imagine if
you haven't really seen all that you
know and you see two three of your
friends just get handled like super
easily almost like this guy's been
training for this exact moment and then
now you're next and you have no training
yeah or maybe some Street training
because that's their camera you just
have no idea what you're doing you you
go to grab the guy and you're literally
getting thrown like a judo like like a
judo player it's hard for you and me to
imagine because we've been training for
so long
it's hard to imagine what it's like to
not have any training yeah you know I
don't remember what it's like to not
know Jiu Jitsu anymore I mean when I
talk about like Master Chief Bailey like
I just remember that instance of like
well this is confusing but I don't
remember what was actually
what it was like the day before that and
like if I would have looked and I've
been in a lot of fights actually growing
up been a lot of fights
but
what my thought process was was just
ignorant in ignorance the wrong word
it's just like a hollow emptiness yeah
like blind like a big blindness yeah
like you don't you don't see anything
you see one or two things and you think
that's the whole story when it's not
even part of the story you just have no
idea
yeah uh talks a little bit more about
the ban on martial arts the ban of
Marshall the band on teaching martial
arts extended to all levels of schools
the Banning of Judo schools one of the
pre-war strongholds of Judo training
seriously impacted the ability of
pre-war judoka to practice and
eliminated hundreds of teaching jobs for
for top judoka as late as 1947 there was
still great confusion about the legal
status of teaching and practicing
traditional martial arts especially in
schools at all levels
it was not until between 1947 and 1950
that controls on the martial arts were
loosened and Judo and other martial arts
were again permitted to be taught in
schools
even if such was then I'm just skimming
some of these highlights of what you
know what he's going through even if
such restrictions had not been imposed
on the teaching and practice Judo many
judoka were no economic position to
spend their time training this was true
of Kimura as well from the end of the
war Kimura was was unable to practice it
all he was trying to support his family
with unstable jobs such as broker for
Coal Sales bodyguard Etc nonetheless
Kimura entered one of the first Judo
tournaments held after the war war 1947
West Japan Judo championship
kimura's Pride anyone that camira's
prize for defeating both opponents was
the equivalent of ten thousand dollars
damn that's pretty good in 1947. hell
yeah
much needed windfall that helped support
his family during the difficult early
post-war years following the tournament
Kimura was promoted to seventh Don
the first all Japan Championship held
since 1941 was was contested on May 2nd
1948 Camira likely would have been a
favorite but was denied entry because of
his refusal to return the championship
flag which he had kept after winning
four consecutive all Japan Championship
tournaments before the war
so this is something that came up and
there basically was given a flag and he
didn't return it to like the Judo people
and they were mad at him and they were
really mad at him that's they didn't
even let him in the tournament
um
Eid Camira did participate in the 1949
all-japan Chomp championship at age 32.
he remembered his match against
Ishikawa one of the toughest and most
consistent opponents
after a second overtime again I'm fast
forwarding there's really cool details
about these about these matches after a
second overtime the judge's decision had
to be rendered all three judges both
raised both red and white flags it was a
draw
the 1949 championships was the highlight
of kimura's Judo career it was the last
time Kimura would compete in the all
Japan Championship leaving him with four
wins and a co-championship so that last
time that he competed he actually had a
draw and there was duel Champions there
shortly after 1949 after winning 1949
all Japan championship
was offered the highly prestigious
position of Judo instructor of the Tokyo
Metropolitan Police he began working
there in April of 1950.
but the salary is insufficient to
support his family now consisting of a
wife son and daughter especially since
his wife had contracted tuberculosis
medicine was extremely rare and
expensive in post-war Japan Kimura could
simply not afford treatment on the
police department's salary and the
reason that this is important to bring
up is because he had to figure out what
to do to get money
luckily there's a new startup
new startup I don't know if they use
that term back in the day but there's a
professional Judo came out in Pro judo's
first tournament Kimura worked his way
through various opponents to reach the
finals where he faces six Don Yamaguchi
toshio Kimura beat Yamaguchi by
osotogari followed by a pin becoming the
first professional Judo Champion then
this guy that he fought Yamaguchi
started getting into the pro wrestling
scene
and there's a whole
a whole story we need to get Josh
Barnett on here to get that we can get
down and get the whole history of
Japanese professional wrestling and
where it came from and how it went and
we got the Americans that came over the
Americans that were catch wrestlers that
went over to Japan and taught these guys
how to do this stuff
um but Kimura got involved in that
and you know went to Hawaii given a
three-month contract to demonstrate Judo
on the Hawaiian Islands
pro wrestling fast forward a little pro
wrestling promoter
we gave him a uh offer to take part in
weekly pro wrestling bounce money was
great he was able to get the medicine
able to buy the medicine for his wife
she was able to recover from her disease
um now meanwhile in Brazil
there was a guy another Judo guy named
Cato Cato weighed about 154 pounds
Elio Gracie weighed 139 Gracie faced
Cato twice in the first match on
September 6 1951 Cato and Gracie met at
the Maracana stadium in Rio De Janeiro
Brazil for a three-round draw
so the first time we had Judo versus
Jujitsu it was a draw guys that were
roughly equal I mean 15 pounds is no
joke honestly but they're more equal
than some of these other matches that
are going on at the time
um then they had
a second Bouch a second bout September
29th 1951. it's only 23 days later
going to uh
a quote or a story told by Kimura about
the second match the rules of the bout
were different from that of Judo or pro
wrestling the winner was decided by
submission only yeah
no matter how cleanly a throw is
executed or how long uh someone was
pinned it does not count he issued the
challenge to Cato fifth Don first the
gong rang Cato is in good condition and
threw Elio a number of times however
past the 15 minute Mark I started again
this is this is kimira watching this I
started to see frustration in Cato's
face the throws had no damage on Elio
since the mat was soft at the 30 minute
mark it was evident that Kato was tired
what's the matter Cato go nawaza don't
stand up the Japanese in the audience
yelled Cato then threw Elio down by
osotogari mounted on Elio
and started a cross hand choke the
audience roared with excitement but as I
watched carefully Alia was also applying
a choke From Below they were trying to
choke out each other this lasted about
three or four minutes Cato's face
started to turn pale I shouted stopped
to the referee and jumped into the ring
when Elio released his hands Cato
collapsed on the mat face first
by beating Cato Gracie became instant
national hero
unfortunately his supporters went
overboard in celebrating his victory as
Kimura remembered it two days after his
bout I saw Elio's students marching down
a city street carrying a coffin
they were shouting dead Japanese judoka
Cato is in this coffin he got killed by
Elio we asked your support for Judo
Master Elio Gracie
there's actually a picture of young Elio
Gracie in here and you know Elio Gracie
in most pictures he looks kind of frail
and weak like look at that picture right
there oh yeah oh damn it's like the only
picture I've seen him where you go oh
yeah you could tell this dude's training
all the time yeah take a look at that
some traps yeah so he's kind of jacked
he's wearing a singlet he's wearing a
wrestling singlet
so
what happens after this Cato gets beat
it's a shame for Judo
Kimura now accepts the match and
so now we have a match of of Kimura
versus Elio Gracie
one of the most significant matches in
the history of martial arts am I wrong
you're not wrong I don't think no I mean
it's one of the most significant
matches in the history of martial arts
and we that's what I opened with is how
Elio Gracie remembered it what he
thought of it
that was what we covered in the opening
of this let's hear let's hear how Kimura
describes this match
he says 20 000 people came to see the
bout including the president of Brazil
IO Gracie was 180 centimeters and 80
kilograms
when I which I think is you know I think
Elio would say he was lighter than that
but because 80 kilograms is 107 165
pounds more than that so yeah and and
yet they usually say Haley was like 145
pounds or something like that
anyways when I entered the stadium
I found a coffin
I asked what it was I was told this is
for Kimura Elio brought this in it was
so funny that I almost burst into
laughter as I approached the ring raw
eggs were thrown at me
the gong ring Elio grabbed me in both
lapels and attacked me with a sotogari
but they did not move me at all now it's
my turn I blew him up in the air
with a bunch of different throws I'm not
going to read them all at about the 10
minute Mark I threw him by a sotogari I
intended to cause a concussion but since
the mat was so soft it did not have much
impact on him while continuing to throw
him I was thinking of a finishing method
I threw him by osotagari again as soon
as Elio fell I pinned him
I held still for two or three minutes
then tried to smother him with my belly
Elio shook his head trying to breathe he
could not take it any longer and tried
to push my body up extending his left
arm that moment I grabbed his left wrist
with my right hand and twisted his arm
I applied
the entangled arm lock or the Kimura
I thought he would surrender immediately
but Elio would not tap the mat
I had no choice but to keep twisting on
his arm the stadium became quiet the
bone of his arm was coming close to
Breaking Point finally the sound of
bone-breaking echoed throughout the
stadium Elio still did not surrender
his left left arm was already powerless
under this rule I had no choice but to
twist the arm again there was plenty of
time left I twisted the arm again
another bone was broken
Elio still did not tap when I tried to
twist the arm once more a white towel
was thrown in I won by TKO my hand was
raised Japanese Brazilians rushed into
the ring and tossed me up in the air on
the other hand Elio left let his arm
hang and looked very sad
withstanding the pain so there's video
of this by the way you can just go watch
this match pretty awesome
um
the the uh the
head line of the newspaper
um says moral victory of he ofelio
Gracie but the funny thing is
the moral Victory the moral part is
really tiny and so it just basically
says victory for Helio Gracie and look
in their minds
they it was a victory because they
thought hey here's a guy that's a lot
lighter a lot smaller a lot less
athletic and he was able to go a long
time against this Champion so it was a
moral victory
for look at look at that look at that
title
so there was definitely the uh some some
bias in the media we'll say back then uh
with that
you know that's like I said one of the
most significant
matches in the history of martial arts
um going back to the book here a little
bit in Fast Forward come here decided to
join the growing and increasingly
popular word of Japanese professional
wrestling in November 1951
and then there's this whole story about
this
up and coming pro wrestling star who had
fought under the stage name of Ricky
dozan
he established his own Wrestling
Federation called the Japan Pro
Wrestling Alliance Riku dozan is often
called the father of Japanese pro
wrestling and is even said without him
there likely would be no such thing as
pro wrestling in Japan Riki dozan had
trained on in karate
and in Sumo and reached the third
highest rank before long Riki design and
Kimura decided to pair up in an effort
to put together a winning Play Bill and
Hike their income now he goes into this
thing about these guys named the sharp
Brothers Ben and Iron Mike both 6'5 and
over 250 pounds so again I'm sure these
are Americans that rolled over there
and they're going to do a uh
they did a series of tag team matches
against Rika Dizon and Kimura against
these two guys the sharp brothers and
this is this is pro wrestling these are
kind of worked matches we're getting
into where we know what's gonna happen
right and this they're trying to
literally like pro wrestling today but
again this Japanese pro wrestling
there's some things that are real that
happen there's things that aren't again
we got to get Josh Barnett
down here with his knowledge exceptional
knowledge of all this stuff to talk us
through it
um
so then this happens
they're growing popularity led the media
and the public to push for about between
chimura and Riki dozan billed as The
Duel of the century the match was to
last 60 minutes
Kimura remembers what happens what
happened next
I met with Rika dozan and asked his
opinion he said that is a good idea we
will be able to build a fortune let's do
it
first bout was going to be a draw
the winner of the second bout would be
determined by paper scissors Stone huh
after the second match we will repeat
this process we came to an agreement on
this condition so this is all just fake
it's fake pro wrestling
as for the content of the match Riki
dozan will let me throw him and I will
let him strike me with a chop and we
rehearse the karate chops and the throws
so this is just a big you know big pro
wrestling show
however once the bout started Ricky
dozan became taken by Greed for big
money and fame he lost his mind and
became a Madman when I saw him raise his
hand I opened my arms to invite the chop
he delivered the chop not to my chest
but to my neck with full force I fell to
the mat then he kicked me neck arteries
are so vulnerable that it did not need
to be Ricky dozant to cause a knockdown
a junior high school kid could inflict a
knock down this way I could not forgive
his treachery that night I received a
phone call informing me that several
tens of Yakuza are on their way to Tokyo
to kill Ricky design
bam yeah that's a Mayhem and he goes on
he goes on um eventually Ricky goes on
he didn't get killed that night but he
died of he died later um
other issues stabbed with a short story
I mean it's that was like 10 10 years
later or something like that
but uh
kind of terrible
you've seen some of those matches gone
wrong oh no wait the Jimmy pro wrestling
no I know I didn't I'm not I wasn't you
see an occasionally someone get caught
in a Kimura actually yeah yeah you see
remnants of that stuff like that people
get pissed
well I always thought it was part of the
show sometimes there's one famous one
where I think Kurt Angle gets caught in
the Kimura by like a young upcoming
wrestler that new Jiu Jitsu and like
puts it on him for real
yeah it's kind of messed up yeah and why
and I don't know the deal
um but I wonder how choreographed or how
like intro do they is every detail kind
of sorted out beforehand or is it just
sort of like hey here's the gig you go
you get ahead and you come back then you
get ahead and then you come back and win
or or like well I don't know what's up
yeah it's like almost like you you have
to go to practice with them I mean I bet
let's say you and I we're gonna do an
exhibition match yeah probably the same
thing we do I'd be like hey man you know
I'll come out and like kind of get let
me get a good throw on you and then I'll
get you in a good position you can
escape yeah and you can start putting
the heat on me and whatever we just
figured on we could we could act that
out pretty easily yeah just with our
knowledge
there's a difference between that of us
getting together beforehand like the day
of and like weeks of like kind of
practicing it together you know I wonder
how in depth it goes because some of
them also actually coincidentally like
within the past week or so I saw it was
um it was a female one and I was like
bruh they didn't really practice this
because there was a lot of dead time now
and kind of confusion you know was it
like a professional like on TV yeah the
one with the lights and the video they
have like they have local pro wrestling
you know oh for you can go check that
out I think I might there's some there's
some wildness
it was freaking awesome guys we're going
crazy like you're looking at them
impressed like this is dangerous like
whatever they're doing I've seen a guy
jump off of a building
I saw a guy jump off of a building in
Ocean Beach California in a wrestling
match jump off of the building and land
in the ring on somebody oh damn like
yeah if I did that or if you did that we
would be hurt 100 yeah 100 pretty much
any building yeah I don't know what kind
of drugs these dudes are on or what
they're taking you know whether they're
on whatever but hey man some pain relief
there you go definitely some pain
reliever scenarios going on I do know
that there's technique though to the to
the safety of for sure so like the um
there he actually used to be this
reality show on like wrestling school or
whatever so I think that's my initial
um Knowledge from like the little
techniques but you know how you know the
one I don't know the names of the moves
but when the guy's laying on his back
and you do like a drop with the back of
your leg you jump up and you land on
with the back of your leg on his face
yeah
yeah like your knees kind of bent or
whatever there's like all these
techniques and even funny that it's a
complete opposite of that
you're just trying to hurt the other
person yeah I mean yeah like you take
away that space yeah make it more
effective but yeah I do wonder how that
is I think um
oh freaking
sakuraba was in that for a bit yes the
pro wrestling definitely was and see
that's the thing in Japan and in MMA and
pro wrestling and shoot wrestling and
there was all kinds of crossover there
were work fights there were not work
fights so there's a there's a lot of
stuff going on there a lot of stuff that
it's hard to follow that's funny how
like the guy
um deviated from the script and then the
Yakuza was immediately on this trail
that is fun not funny but that's
interesting right there yeah and then
you wonder did they have bets on it I
mean were they betting on this even
though everyone knew it was fake like
what's going on or he's not allowed to
do that kind of violation I know right
ruining the show for us maybe that I'm
sure there's a bunch of other stuff
that's kind of dependent you know riding
on on that show it's been weird you can
always hear uh like when Rogan's talking
to somebody that they're into pro
wrestling he doesn't get like I'm that
way too like I can't I can't I can't buy
into it you know I can't be like oh
that's cool like Rick Rubin the other
day Rick rubin's a huge fan of pro
wrestling
he's like talking about how it's more
like life than you've ever seen like I
do I mean I'm sure at some point we'll
talk through it but him and uh Tony uh
Hinchcliffe he's totally into it yeah
and I've heard you know him and it seems
like
Joe has a hard time with like figuring
out why it's cool and I'm I agree with
Joe like it's hard when you can watch
two humans fight in a cage
for real why would you possibly want to
watch two people act it out it just
doesn't make sense to me yeah yeah I'm
sure there's something we're missing as
far as the pro wrestling in life
parallel but you never know right I mean
how much of pro wrestling do you watch
yeah I don't watch enough man you know I
don't watch enough I I it's hard for me
to watch it because it takes a long time
too yeah you know what you know what I
will give up I will concede you know
when you see a clip you know a clip of
some pro wrestling yeah that might be
pretty cool yeah you know like uh back
in the day when all of a sudden the gong
would go because the Undertaker is like
showing up sure more like Stone Cold
Steve Austin yeah like whatever entry
wild entry he has yeah you know so
you're right about it there's some
dramatic elements that we give credit to
yeah so and when you consider that part
of it and I'm remembering back to my
childhood days where I didn't really
watch the whole thing but you know like
they'd have the commercials for it I'd
be like bro that event whatever they're
doing in there what they're doing
whatever they're doing that looks fun so
and then you have all these crazy
characters like when The Rock was in his
Heyday and when do you smell what The
Rock is good because we were waiting for
that we were waiting for him to say that
and then you know like and you know he
you know what he's about to do because
he has the whole ritual you know the the
people's eyebrow and all this stuff so
um
so when they came out with like the real
characters like in the earliest I
remember is the there was like two twin
brothers and they had a movie or
whatever but it was like that era it's
like 80s and then um
freaking Ultimate Warrior yeah Hulk
Hogan like all those guys when they when
they were like these these characters
so that event just started getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
yeah and then these stunts are all crazy
or whatever so yeah you individualize
like a certain sequence or a certain
like action or whatever oh yeah I see it
I see it yeah but at the end of the day
I think what you're talking about or
what we're talking about is
when you watch two guys like in UFC
we'll say and they're really fighting
you don't know who's gonna win you don't
know how this is gonna be hard it's
gonna be a tough fight it's real fight
if he gets elbowed or need in the face
bro it's like there's some real
consequences and then you're like okay
this one's obviously like choreographed
like obviously that part of it is hard I
guess what we're missing is you know to
give credit to Rick Rubin and Tony
Hinchcliffe is like
if they're tracking that whole story
it's like have you ever watched Breaking
Bad
someone or some series some series on TV
where there's a bunch of characters and
their stuff happening and so you go this
is a cool story and we're gonna follow
it yeah yeah I've never participated
enough in that thing to really like
understand all the stuff that's going on
so that is probably why those guys are
into it and super hype about it and I
doubt that Joe has ever participated in
enough or paid enough attention to be
like wait a second who's gonna win
tonight yeah yeah because it's real easy
just to be like who's gonna win tonight
there's no winning yeah so I'm not gonna
watch it it's not really yeah exactly so
but that but that's a good point though
and
because yeah like you got to make an
investment in it yes like and I'm not
really really I'm really honestly not
willing to invest in something when I
could I would much rather watch two
people fight for real so D and you you
mentioned Breaking Bad so did you watch
Breaking Bad is that one where you kind
of know oh remember when that happened
do you know kind of the storyline give
or take
Breaking Bad yeah yeah it's it's a story
it's one big story right so are you
familiar with that particular story
though yeah I mean I am now that I
watched it yes I can't call it all right
off the top of my head yeah so perfect
so if you if you get into a show like
that and you know you got Netflix is
really good at that right now like the
format is like oh you can't wait for the
next one kind of thing see what happens
all the stuff all these charts
so it's essentially that but in the
wrestling Combat Sports format and
honestly I don't even know if there is a
sustaining plot through the professional
wrestling I don't even know I might be
that might not be I don't know uh and
actually you're right so I will here's
my my uh my statement if there is I can
see it now yeah yeah good before it's
like all this other stuff sure we know
so just like we know Breaking Bad is not
real you know if you're there to really
see a real meth lab be operated then
you're not gonna like Breaking Bad
because you'll be like this is just not
real you know but if you like the story
it grabbed you or whatever I think pro
wrestling and I can see how they could
do a good job too with these characters
bro I totally see it yeah
John Cena
so
you know the idea of when um not the
idea but uh they take John C there's a
clip I don't know if it's just one clip
or they always say it or what and he
says and his name is John Cena you ever
heard that nope what okay this is the I
know a little bit about maybe the 80s
wrestlers and then maybe that some of
the 90s wrestlers like we're talking
Hulk Hogan Ultimate Warrior Undertaker
Stone Cold Steve Austin maybe even a
little bit further back like Andre the
Giant and and the Iron Sheik but again
never in any moment in my life were they
anything more than like uh highlight
reel yeah yeah at the same boat for sure
but these clips are so like used for a
bunch of other stuff now so it's like
his name is John Cena's page oh yeah
because he has DDP Yoga he's out there
getting after it seems to help people
out good for DDP oh yeah
um
but it's so like hype you know where
it's like and his name is Johnson I'm
sure they say it at a very specific time
I I actually don't think I've I recall
them actually using that clip in real
life I've never seen heard it or seen it
be done but now they'll do it on videos
where like you know like if um
you ever seen that video henzo always
freaking posted or he so he's posted
where it's like two guys are fighting
right and then somebody comes like out
of Noah and comes with like a huge jump
kick whatever so this is for example how
they would use that clip it's just the
audio clip his name is John Cena then it
plays this music
so that it'll have like a unrelated
video right of two people really
fighting in real life like a street
fight or something like a crowd bar
fight or something and then someone come
flying out of nowhere and then they'd
say they'd play the clip audio and his
name is John Cena right when they land
the kick and he goes and it's this big
thing
so that hype that they have isolated and
individualized
when I understand and feel that hype
when they play it on all kinds of
different clips by the way
that feeling that I get if even a
fraction of that is involved in pro
wrestling I get it yeah there you go all
right Tony Hinchcliffe and Rick Rubin
carry on
and yeah guys we're down we're our minds
are open understand to your things here
uh fast forward a little bit March 1955
Camira went to Mexico to do pro
wrestling matches in November he
traveled to French to teach Johto during
Judo during the daytime and do pro
wrestling matches at night he did the
same for London spending a year in Paris
in London from their Camira traveled to
Spain for foremost teach Judo and pro
wrestling you can kind of see where his
life is heading to
um back to Brazil in 1959 returned to
Brazil what would be his last pro
wrestling in Judo tour
he was challenged by valdemar Santana
27 year old champion of Gracie Jiu Jitsu
capoeira and boxing Kimura claimed that
Santana had a fourth Dawn in Judo though
this may have been his rank in Gracie
Jiu Jitsu at six foot 205 pounds he was
taller heavier and much younger than
Kimura now 42.
the year before Santana had knocked out
Elio Gracie in a fight lasting three
hours and 45 minutes that's no no time
limit activity right there uh so these
two guys fight
Camira through Santana
applied his uh chimura lock then they
did a rematch this rematch was Valley
tudo
Camira hurt his left knee uh the
promoter insisted that they fight anyway
he says if you refuse to fight today the
angry audience Will Set Fire To The
Arena if this Arena got burned to Ash I
would make you accountable for the
damage so he gets pressured into this
fight with little Choice Kimura went
ahead with the fight
I'm gonna give some pretty good detail
around the fight he says I traded kicks
with him the entire audience was
standing with excitement even in this
situation I was able to think clearly
I was thinking he's one level higher
than I both in kicks and open hand
strikes in order when I must take the
fight to the ground
fast forward a little bit all of a
sudden I received a head cracking impact
I experienced a tremendous ear ringing
got momentarily unconscious I had
received a headbutt on my left temple it
was a head butt from the side I had
thought that all headbutts would come
from the front I never knew of a side
head but
then he says I cannot lose here I must
win even if I may die I thought driven
by this willpower I tried to fight find
a way to fight back the referee came
between us to separate us we were
already covered in blood the fight was
brought back to the center of the Ring
again
he threw an open right hand strike I
caught the arm and attempted a throw it
seemed like it would score I would score
a clean throw however it was a
miscalculation we were both heavily
covered with sweat as if a large amount
of water had been poured onto our heads
moreover he had no jacket on there was
no way such a technique could have
worked under these conditions his arm
slipped through and my body rotated in
air once forward and I landed on my back
so this is classic right he tries a judo
throw but they're all sweaty I mean it's
kind of crazy when we're doing Jiu Jitsu
it's like oh yeah the sweat here of like
oh yeah I can't do that when it's sweaty
we literally say that now even about
you know heel hooks like someone's super
sweaty the heel gets hard to get a heel
hook harder arm lock someone gets super
sweaty it's harder to get throws judo
throws real hard
I screwed up I shouted in my mind but it
was too late he immediately jumped at me
if he got on my chest he could freely
strike My Eyes Nose chest with his
elbows I caught him in a body scissors I
squeezed his body with full force hoping
to sever his intestine he crumbled
momentarily but did not surrender since
the body scissors did not finish him I
realized that I was in a disadvantageous
position when I lifted my head I saw
when I left in my head hundreds of stars
flew out of my eyes I took a straight
punch in the nose and my eyes it was an
accurate intense punch the back of my
head got slammed onto the mat moreover
an intense headbutt attacked my abdomen
I felt like my organs would be torn into
pieces once twice I hardened my
abdominal muscles to withstand the
impact and waited for a third attack at
the moment the third headbutt came my
right fist accurately caught his face by
counter it landed between his nose and
eyes blood spattered I had also been
heavily covered in blood the blood
interfered with my vision kill him kill
him the devil in my mind screamed he
wobbled and stepped back and tried to
run with the ropes on his back I chased
him throwing kicks and open hand strikes
he returned head butts and elbow strikes
but neither of us was able to deliver a
decisive strike maybe we were both
exhausted or maybe the blood in our eyes
prevented us from aiming clearly at the
Target after all the 40 minutes ran out
and the match ended in a draw
hmm
I don't know I didn't look for that one
on YouTube to see if it's on there
uh getting into the final years
Kimura returned to Japan retired from
competition 1960 took up a position of
Judo instructor at his Alma Mater
University
he was highly successful coach he
trained a bunch of Champions
his final years however were marred by
the petty vindictiveness of the Koda
Khan authorities who froze his rank at
Seventh Dawn because he had refused to
return the championship flag he believed
he had earned a 1939 and because he had
promoted a number of people in Brazil
the black belt ranks in Judo without
authorization from the kodacon his
professional wrestling experience also
upset powerful figures who controlled
Judo Rank and who thought he had
demeaned the art by engaging in this
form of entertainment
he remained a seventh on from the age of
30 until his death at 75.
I'm gonna close this out here he says
Camira never lost his Spirit however he
continued to teach and train even while
many of those he had defeated were
promoted to eighth ninth and even 10th
Dawn in the early 1990s Kimura a
lifelong smoker was diagnosed with lung
cancer
hospitalized after surgery and in his
70s Kimura started doing push-ups in his
room
he died on April 18 1993 at the age of
75 arguably the best Judo competitor
ever and one of the most important Judo
figures ever to be mistreated by the
leaders of his art
so
there you go
um always important to know your history
always important to know your roots
always important to learn some lessons
here and uh just a cool book
from Christopher M Clark once again the
book is called the triumphs and tragedy
of one of Japan's greatest and most
controversial Judo champions
um
good place to learn some lessons and to
see where we can improve where we can
become stronger faster smarter better
see where we can become a little bit
more
like Kimura
so there you go
Echo Charles if we're going to be
getting better
we need to fuel the system let's get
some Jocko fuel some jockoffuel.com
I was up at this big Food Expo thing
sure and at this big food extra I saw a
bunch of people there they're coming up
to me and they're saying I didn't know
you made supplements I didn't know you
made an energy drink I didn't you know
you made a protein drink
a decent amount of people I would say
half the people that came and said hi to
me were like oh I didn't know you had
this which means I know I do a terrible
job of putting the word out there so
jockoffuel.com we make the best
supplements in the world straight up yep
so check that out check out
jockoffuel.com get yourself some ready
to drink mole get yourself one of these
drinks here energy drinks
uh without the stigma by the way yeah
that's good for you your kids can drink
it you know like we made it as good as
you can possibly make these things so we
get stuff for your joints if you're
gonna be doing Judo Jiu Jitsu and
wrestling and Muay Thai and boxing your
joints are going to be need a little
they're going to need a little Comfort a
little love need a little get yourself
some joint Warfare get yourself elf
get yourself some time more by the way
yeah we're trying not to get older yeah
right get that time War it's basically
designed
for your entire Health profile
especially the longevity profile
so we just brought that out check that
one out you can get the stuff Toco
field.com you can get it at Wawa you get
the drinks at Wawa you can get them at
Vitamin Shoppe you get all the stuff at
Vitamin Shoppe military commissaries
Hannaford's Dash stores in Maryland wake
Fern ShopRite Circle K HEB
and Meyer
we got it going on
um Circle K did I say Circle K yeah so a
bunch of different great stores you can
get this stuff
uh also if you're doing Jiu Jitsu if
you're doing Judo you're gonna need some
gear you need to wear a ghee
originusa.com get yourself a ghee get
yourself a rash guard if you're doing no
ghee
get yourself some spats if you're
wearing spats or get yourself some
shorts all the stuff made in America
no no one's being enslaved
like they are if you buy some other
brand that's that's
Contracting out a sweatshop in Southeast
Asia
or in China to make your gear by some 11
year old girl that's getting paid 12
cents a day
don't do don't participate in that no
reason
made in America even the Fabrics are
made in America boots jeans joggers
t-shirts hoodies originusa.com go get
some uh with that light wash Delta 68
yesterday to the mall okay I don't go to
the mall but I did it was my daughter's
birthday Etc things happen yeah things
happen but the first time I wore the
light wash during the day yeah very
comfortable actionable you know you can
do some squats if you want in them I
didn't but I did get this a massive
compliment for my lovely wife and she
said they look good on you there you go
there you go fashion and function
on the function thing but obviously
Mrs Charles is focused on the the
fashion side hey if you're gonna get a
fashion compliment from someone who it
means something to and from yeah
or to usa.com to go check it out that's
a good one also Jaclyn's store called
Jocko store this is where you can
represent shirts hats hoodies all that
stuff with discipline equals Freedom
represent that on this path we're not
training nine hours a day nessus
literally but if you are I ain't I'm not
gonna say nothing yeah get your benches
yes whatever you like nonetheless you're
representing while you're doing these
things so we're just cruising just
walking around whatever you can do that
and you can get it from
chocolatestore.com also this is shirt
Locker got a new shirt every month with
different types of cool designs still
representing the path by the way but
it's a subscription scenario so yeah
check that one out it's called the shirt
Locker it's on shoplostore.com subscribe
to the podcast check out Jocko
underground Jack underground.com we're
about to record one of those action when
we get done here we've covered some
other topics we do q a it's also a
platform that we own
so we can say whatever we want we can't
get banned it's band proof it's cancel
proof
if you can't afford eight dollars and 18
cents a month we get it it's okay email
assistance at Jocko underground.com but
we just want you there with us
in the underground don't forget we have
a YouTube channel subscribe to that
originusa Jocko fuel also have YouTube
channels we have psychological warfare
we got Flipside canvas bunch of books
this here book once again Kimura the
triumphs and tragedy of one of Japan's
greatest and most controversial Judo
champions
it's written by Christopher M Clark so
check that out get yourself some history
know your history don't forget about the
way the Warrior Kids books I mean come
on you want your kid to be raised with
discipline but it's hard to impose on
them but when they voluntarily want it
because they understand it it's gonna
make your whole life better it's going
to make their lives better way of the
warrior kids series go check those out
obviously I've written a bunch of other
books as well we also have a leadership
consultancy go to echelonfront.com if
you need help inside your organization
we can solve all your problems
through leadership we have a online
training program for that it's called
Extreme ownership.com go to extreme
ownership.com take courses come and ask
me questions I'm on there live once a
week
you can just sit there and ask me about
what's going on with your co-worker
what's going on with your husband what's
going on with your wife what's going on
with your kids what's going on with Jiu
Jitsu you got a question to ask come and
ask it
live better
extreme ownership.com
also if you want to help families
service members
active and retired you want to help gold
star families check out Markley's mom
mommy she's got a great charity
organization if you want to donate or
you want to get involved go to America's
mightywarriors.org and don't forget
about Micah Fink
Heroes and horses.org latest update
from the Wilderness apparently at this
time Micah Fink is in a snow cave
he has killed a mountain lion and he is
making a
jacket
from the mountain lion stand that's
what's going on through the latest
reports you know unverified at this time
sure but you know we have faith if you
want to connect with us on the on the
social media
Echoes at Echo Charles I'm at Jocko
willing just watch out for the algorithm
it's there it's there it's it's
literally
artificial intelligence that's meant to
make you watch it more that's its whole
purpose you want people like oh AI is
not going to be evil some people like oh
AI is evil I'm going to tell you that AI
is evil
it's a little dopamine dealer and it's
in there going
spreading it around got you
isn't it embarrassing that it gets you
yeah kind of embarrassing feels
embarrassing yeah but why what do you
mean it feels but it's not I put it this
way I don't discount what I'm up against
so uh in hindsight see I'm saying
because the thing is made specifically
just like oh you said yeah made
specifically for you for you like in a
way it probably is not doesn't think
it's evil it probably thinks it's good
it's probably like hey you know what I
care about this job yeah yeah doing its
job it cares about you it cares the
internet knows what you like because you
told it what it like smothering mother
that thinks she's doing a good thing by
like smothering the kid with you know
all this love and joy and toys and
cookies and crackers and that kid ends
up week it's true that's the Perfect
Analogy like oh I saw his his his
beautiful smile after I gave him that
cupcake so what I'm gonna do another one
give them another one maybe another
flavor don't mean dope with me dopamine
dopamine all right so watch out for that
algorithm watch out for that dopamine
dealer that's locked inside your phone
waiting to get out
he doesn't even he's working 24 hours a
day by the way he's a freaking robot he
doesn't get him he's not getting paid
he's just in there just just uh an
inanimate
thing
is taking your time stealing your life
from you just watch out for it and
thanks to all the true Warriors in our
military that are out there on the front
lines protecting Freedom around the
world also thanks to our police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers border
patrol Secret Service all First
Responders thank you for protecting us
here at home and to everyone else out
there you know there's a doing my
research on Kimura
there's an interview
from a 1987 issue of full contact karate
magazine and curios is a bunch of stuff
you can Google it but one thing he says
is you can't just lie around sleeping
like everybody else
that's how we trained three times harder
than his opponents that's how he was
lifting that's how he was training
that's how he was conditioning that's
what he did that's how he became
Champion by getting up every day
and getting after it
and I actually recommend
that you do the same
and until next time this is Echo and
Jocko
out